para cualquier persona que haya vivido
en Europa el último año el más reciente
informe del estado del clima europeo no
traerá sorpresas de acuerdo con el texto
del viejo continente experimentó en 2022
su verano más caluroso jamás ha
registrado y su segundo año más caliente
el reporte también revela Que las
temperaturas a lo largo de Europa están
aumentando el doble sobre la media
global con un repunte de 2,2 grados
Celsius desde los niveles
preindustriales
esta combinación de olas de calor y
condiciones mucho más calurosas al
promedio a lo largo del año llevan a
incrementar la carga de calor y sabemos
por nuestros datos que ese calor intenso
bajo el que los ciudadanos europeos
estuvieron en 2022 fue el más alto al
que han estado sometidos
estas altas temperaturas de la mano de
pocas lluvias también derivaron en una
amplia sequía a lo largo del año
mientras que los incendios de verano
causaron emisiones de carbono a niveles
récord Sí el nivel en 2022 de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
en la atmósfera fue el más alto jamás
registrado así que tenemos un núcleo de
hielo y otros registros paleo climáticos
que se remontan para la antártica
cientos de miles de años atrás y para el
metano creo que se remonta hace dos
millones de años realmente sabemos de
manera empírica que las concentraciones
de gases de efecto invernadero en la
atmósfera son las más altas en un
periodo de tiempo increíble
los efectos se sintieron en todas partes
Incluso en áreas más frías según el
texto los alpes perdieron Casi más de 5
kilómetros cúbicos de hielo una ola de
calor poco usual en septiembre sobre
Groenlandia resultó también en un
derretimiento récord del manto de hielo
el mundo avanza hacia un sistema
climático como el del fenómeno del niño
que podría concluir en un mayor
incremento de las temperaturas